>> WHAT HE ADDED TO OUR
POLITICAL DISCOURSE WAS LARGELY
SARCASM, INSULTS, AND DISHONEST
EDITING.
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S CLEARLY
SELECTIVE EDITING OF CLIPS.
>> I CAN SPEAK PERSONALLY TO A
LOT OF THE ATTACKS THAT WERE
LEVIED ON ME HAD NO FOOTHOLDS IN
THE FACTS.
>> WHY I -- DISHONEST AND NO
FOOTHOLD IN THE FACT?
YOU HAVE CASTED ASPERSIONS UPON
MY HONOR!
( LAUGHTER )
AND I DEMAND SATISFACTION!
I CHALLENGE YOU, FOX NEWS TO A
LIE-OFF.
( LAUGHTER )
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
YOUR DISTORTIONS AND LACK OF
FACT FOOTHOLDS AGAINST MINE.
TO START US OFF HERE ARE 50 OF
YOURS IN SIX SECOND VINE.
( CLOCK TICKING )
( LAUGHTER )
PLENTY MORE WHERE THAT CAME
FROM.
ONLY HAVE A 22-MINUTE SHOW.
ACTUALLY YOU JUST GO TO THE WEB
SITE AND PURUSE EACH LIE AT YOUR
LEISURE.